[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur sensation
je suis aujourd'hui avec Florence qui a
moins directrice du Théâtre Coluche à
Plaisir bonjour on va parler de la
programmation de votre salle de
spectacle avant ça j'aimerais parler de
vos ambitions en termes de culture sur
le territoire le théâtre Coluche a une
grande capacité d'accueil est-ce que
votre premier souhait c'est d'établir
une programmation éclectique pour
toucher tous les publics c'est
exactement ça c'est à dire que je vise
les jeunes les plus jeunes de des
tout-petits de la première section de
maternelle jusqu'au seniors qui sont
pour la plupart le public idéal des
théâtres ça change ça commence à
vraiment changer puisqu'il y a
maintenant on veut absolument accueillir
les les familles et la saison prochaine
ça sera vraiment centrée sur les
familles d'ailleurs justement vous vous
l'avez évoqué vous vous proposez des des
spectacles à partir de 3 ans pourquoi le
théâtre doit être découvert dès le plus
jeune âge mais que sinon on va les
perdre c'est le public de demain il faut
il faut les initier et c'est vrai que au
début c'est un public captif on les
amène au théâtre c'est les écoles qui
les amènent mais si ça leur laisse des
souvenirs inoubliables ils reviendront
par eux-mêmes et ça c'est essentiel à
l'époque de des chaînes de télé de
Netflix de toutes les plateformes il
faut absolument que les jeunes
découvrent le plaisir du direct du
direct du live de la vie de spectacle de
50 ans en Yvelines proposent de nombreux
spectacles tout au long de l'année vous
travaillez notamment avec la clé des
champs qui est également à plaisir sur
la programmation de certains spectacles
ou concert pourquoi les acteurs
culturels doivent travailler main dans
la main selon vous parce que c'est un
ensemble en fait c'est la culture c'est
pas le théâtre d'un côté moi je suis
j'ai une je dirige une scène
pluridisciplinaire donc on dit le
théâtre Coluche mais au théâtre Coluche
c'est des concerts du cirque de l'humour
tout tout les disciplines sont
représentées donc j'ai la chance
exceptionnelle d'avoir une scène de
musique actuelle la clé des champs qui a
une programmation que je vous recommande
qui est formidable qui est diversifié
qui est jeune avec un état d'esprit
vraiment festif il y a je crois deux
concerts par mois mais franchement il
faut la découvrir cette programmation là
c'est une salle qui depuis un an avec sa
nouvelle direction a complètement évolué
et justement vous les accompagnez vous
travaillez vous travaillez avec eux on
va désormais parler de la programmation
le 7 avril vous proposez le spectacle
les encres fraîches un spectacle hors
les murs puisqu'il se passe justement à
la clé des champs qu'est-ce qui attend
le public pour cette soirée alors c'est
un peu plus qu'un spectacle c'est je
travaille depuis des années sur
sur les écritures les encres fraîches
les écritures nouvelles d'auteurs de
théâtre vivant et donc on montre en
maquette on fait des maquettes mais avec
une vraie mise en scène le texte et lui
bien sûr mais il y a des lumières il y a
des musiciens qui font une vraie
création musicale l'auteur est présent
et à la fin il y a un échange avec le
plus public c'est extrêmement
enrichissant l'auteur en temps pour la
première fois son texte dit par des
comédiens et
ce sont des des textes qui ont une vie
derrière qui vont avoir une production
je citerai puisque c'est assez récent
respire joué par Romane Bohringer
alaskala que que j'ai fait découvrir à
des spectateurs pendant des encres
fraîches donc c'est assez génial c'est
une espèce de d'avant-première c'est un
cadeau faire au public puisque c'est
l'entrée est absolument gratuite il faut
quand même un petit peu réserver avant
parce que ben on est dans la petite
salle donc on peut pas accueillir plus
de 100 personnes et ce qui est génial
c'est que le lendemain on fait un autre
texte le jeune public un texte de
Laurent Contamin avec 10 jeunes 10
jeunes qui sont issus des Clash chatte
du collège et quelques-uns qui sont
issus de la classe théâtre du
conservatoire et ils vont avoir leur
auteur qui va les entendre pour la
première fois dire son texte et qui
peuvent pas pouvoir échanger avec eux
c'est encore un magnifique cadeau les
élèves du collège Blaise Pascal ça sera
donc le 8 avril et ça s'appelle le
soleil le soleil de moze le 7 avril
c'est c'est gratuit pourquoi est-ce que
vous vous souhaitez justement mettre des
événements gratuits des spectacles
gratuits parce que c'est la curiosité là
que je veux vraiment provoquer chez les
gens
oser oser venir vous ne risquez rien
peut-être que vous allez vous ennuyer
mais si vous êtes en si vous vous êtes
ennuyé vous pourrez le dire directement
à l'auteur il lui expliquait pourquoi et
là il y a des débats géniaux en général
les gens de s'ennuient pas et le petit
problème de ça c'est qu'ils nous disent
mais il y a pas besoin de monter le
spectacle en fait on a tout là ce qu'il
faut mais voilà ils adorent le 16 avril
on passe à de la danse hip-hop avec
Casse-Noisette de Blanca Lee c'est au
théâtre Coluche qui est blanc Cali et
pourquoi avoir programmé ce spectacle au
Théâtre connu parce que c'est une de nos
plus grandes chorégraphes espagnoles et
puis j'adore l'état d'esprit espagnol
totalement décalé et elle a elle
dépoussière complètement Casse-Noisette
alors il y a quelques petits extraits de
l'original du palais original mais c'est
totalement détourné c'est hyper drôle
c'est à l'espagnol c'est enlevé c'est du
hip-hop comment comme on en voit
rarement une découverte de
Casse-Noisette c'est même pas des
scriptible en fait que les gens vont
voir si c'est hyper drôle c'est hyper
virtuose en terme de danse mais vraiment
et tellement inventif elle va avril
Fabien olicard sera sur la scène du
théâtre Coluche pour son one-man show
archétype on va écouter un extrait de
son passage au Montreux comédie et on
poursuit juste après ça vous
impressionne toujours un peu ce genre de
choses alors je vous rassure on est des
hommes comme les autres sauf qu'on est
mentalistes il y a quelques années quand
je disais aux gens que j'étais
mentaliste personne savait ce que
c'était alors que maintenant grâce à la
série The Mentalist personne sait ce que
c'est ça n'a rien changé du tout quand
on dit mentaliste on pense souvent à
magicien ou à voyant il y a une
différence entre les deux un des
magiciens utilisent les colombes les
voyants cherchent les pigeons c'est pas
le même volatile moi je crois que le
mentalisme c'est deux choses c'est une
manière d'influencer vos choix et de
savoir ce que vous pensez par exemple
mademoiselle c'est
non c'est très flatteur ce que tu penses
surtout
merci Charline
elle me regarde elle a fait mon pauvre
garçon pas du tout bon je vous rassure
ce soir on va commencer doucement avec
la graphologie avec moi trois cartes de
visite au dos desquelles j'ai mis un
questionnaire je vais les donner à trois
d'entre vous les personnes qui veulent
activement participer ce soir vous
pouvez lever la main ce qui n'arrive
jamais
c'est sur les gens bizarres vous êtes
donc deux voilà comme ça je vous ai
repéré c'est cool et ben Charline tu as
parlé tu vas partir tiens Charline un
questionnaire un stylo Fabien olicard
c'est donc le 20 Avril au théâtre
Coluche et il me semble du coup que
c'est complet mais franchement là il va
falloir se mettre en liste d'attente
parce que on pourra peut-être libérer
des places dernière minute mais voilà
c'est liste d'attente là
c'est c'est un un humoriste et
mentaliste du coup qui qui a joué au
Montreux vous accueillez justement
régulièrement des personnes on va dire
connues ou en tout cas réputé pourquoi
est-ce que vous décidez également de de
à la fois faire découvrir des des des
troubles de théâtre des nouveaux des
nouveaux spectacles etc mais aussi des
des spectacles que tout le monde peuvent
connaître comme des one man show même
déjà on a une très grande salle il faut
la remplir donc il faut il faut penser
au tout public à tout le monde à tous
les types de public et aussi
oser oser faire du théâtre qui va pas
faire 900 spectateurs qui va en faire
peut-être que 300 400 mais des gens qui
sont passionnés par un sujet qui sont
vraiment curieux qui ont envie de
découvrir et de se laisser porter et
puis j'espère que maintenant le public
commence à me faire vraiment confiance
parce que je fais mon maximum pour qu'il
y ait une innovation à la fin de chaque
spectacle et pour finir j'aimerais qu'on
parle de la date du 12 mai sur votre
site vous proposez au spectateur de
voyager à travers la galaxie princière
alors qu'est-ce qui nous attend pour
cette soirée ah génial c'est des c'est
des jeunes des jeunes très reconnus qui
sont qui se produisent très
régulièrement New Morning qui accompagne
les plus grands mais vraiment les plus
grands ils ont un talent fou et là le
chanteur Malka mais il revisite prince
c'est prodigieux c'est prodigieux il y a
des choristes il y a il y a tout un
groupe où ils sont une dizaine une
quinzaine sur scène avec les choristes
mais vraiment moi je suis franchement
j'étais pas fan de Prince et grâce à eux
maintenant je suis devenue fan mais
finalement c'est un spectacle à ne pas
louper parce que c'est pour tout le
monde là voilà c'est pas que pour les
[Musique]
je sens qu'ils ont envie de venir au
théâtre plus souvent donc il y aura un
peu plus de spectacles en matinée le
samedi ou le dimanche qui seront
vraiment ouverts pour toutes les
familles c'est à dire de 3 à 90 des
spectacles très ludiques très originaux
aussi très très originaux mais là j'ai
rien dire tout de suite la présentation
c'est le vendredi 16 juin à 20h30 et je
vous espère nombreux je sais que les
gens sont sont très à l'écoute ils
aiment beaucoup ses présentations parce
que j'essaye de les rendre et
extrêmement ludique et c'est le moment
unique pour rencontrer les artistes le
16 juin et en attendant à votre salle de
de spectacle merci beaucoup Florence
d'avoir été avec nous sur sensation et
pour revoir ou réécouter cette émission
rendez-vous sur notre site et notre
application radio sensation
[Musique]